you mentioned that when you're in the
interviews you're trying to be as
engaged as you can be
and that's something that but at the
same time you have to wear different
hats because you're wondering about the
audience
maybe there are other factors that
you're weighing and that's something
that i struggle with as well
and for better or worse i err on the
side of
me being engaged and asking the
questions that i'm more interested in
regardless of if they use too much
jargon or technical depth even if some
audience members will find it extremely
simplistic or
overly complicated and
i imagine that limits the audience and i
could
monetarily benefit from a larger one and
then invest in it so that then later i
could go back to my previous style
but it's a balancing act and i'm
wondering what do you
weigh and how do you make that decision
so marketing is one
your engagement the answering of your
own questions is another
how do you navigate that that process
you know in one sense honestly i don't
try to navigate it i try to be
as engaged and pos as possible and have
the audience
come with us and many people say that
you know they don't understand a lot of
the
shows but they love watching it anyway
and we'll watch it over and over again
we have many many people like that and i
love that
about closer to truth in fact it's one
of the
one of the highlights of closer to truth
is to see the diversity
of people who are engaged and i've i've
kind of come to my own theory about this
is that there are there is this subset
of humanity
that really are engaged with these big
questions
of um of consciousness life after death
how did the universe
happen why is there something rather
than nothing is there a god all those
kinds of questions
and that no externality by
age democr economic level
race religion creed national origin
none of those factors are relevant
i'm exaggerating maybe a little bit to
to their engagement with with these
questions
uh the the best example that i can
remember was a viewer in the
early days of close to the truth a woman
who wrote in and said
you know i've i've only had a high
school education
uh but i love closer that you'll love
the questions that you ask
and he said but i have my husband and i
have five sons
they think i'm nuts you know one's one
one drives a truck and one is uh one and
uh
is a manager at a warehouse and they
think their mother is absolutely crazy
to be interested and watch this
this show this obscure show and you said
but recently my 13 year old grandson
has engaged and has loved these
questions so
he and i my 13 year grandson and i
secretly watch closer to truth when my
husband and my sons and his father are
not around
uh and to me that's a wonder was a
wonderful story
because superficially you would never
say that
woman and that child were
closer to truth's demographic focus
um and so that
that to me is exciting and so therefore
i don't
tr we don't try to reach a demographic
um now as you get bigger people force
you to do that and so i'm not saying
repair but
the the original concept of closer to
truth is you know build it
and see who comes um i remember when
you know mel rogers on koce uh you know
more than 20
22 or so years ago now uh
said you know maybe we can we can run it
and i i you know i said to him even if
you run it at three in the morning and
it's only on koce
i'm excited to do this because i it was
the passion
of the ideas and the opportunity and
if people watch it and when they do and
now you know we have
terrific numbers all over the world on
closer truth youtube and closer to
truth.com
um you know that that's a that's a um
a great satisfaction but the
satisfaction is not that oh yes we were
right no
no the satisfaction is that there are
other people in the world
who have gone through the same things
that i have
and have these same questions and we're
sharing it together
in in this global community that we're
all together and it
it transcends all the externalities that
um seem to divide us more so in today's
world
that the the kinds of questions that we
deal with and you deal with curt
simile are the questions that unite us
across all different
uh you know breaking all different
barriers